that's all it takes
hey 32 this is jill with the white house
at the white house north lawn
hey there hey listen we have jeff
bennett here in case you've got you can
do a stand-up with him
um on
fiverr
yeah you should see him he's standing in
front of the camera right now
it's a white shirt
okay uh you can talk to him
yes
um
so
uh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
okay
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen four
eight fifteen
which signals
hmm
please
podium check one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten audio check one
two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
uh
watching
stress
all right
yes one two three four five
six seven eight nine
what's going on
um
all right
right
he really did you know
huh
hey how are ya
uh
my sister now
that's right andrea and one of the
reasons why the recently confirmed
security secretary is coming into the
brief terms to brief today i'm told it's
because
the white house is keenly aware of the
criticism that president biden
is facing frustrations
that by housing hybrid children he is in
many ways returning to one of the most
controversial
and inhumane aspects policies of the
trump administration
and that is the long-term detention of
undocumented
minors i'll tell you though that the
main focus here at this white house
today is still on covet
relief we heard from the president
briefly on saturday after the house
narrowly
passed uh that 1.9 trillion dollar
package he called for a quick set of
action
and with an eye towards passing it
swiftly in the senate the senate
democrats are now tabling entirely that
effort to include
in the package that 15 minimum wage
uh
right and the view from the
administration is that the the push to
raise the minimum wage
that can be fought another day but kobe
really that the
need there is urgent and that it's
imperative and that if the machinations
of the back and forth about how to raise
the minimum wage
slows down the code relief package then
that's not good for anyone
and president biden himself said weeks
ago to cbs it was that
super bowl interview where he said he
couldn't end the bill but he didn't
think it would survive well it turns out
it didn't survive
you
uh
so
hi everyone
okay today we have a very special guest
homeland security
secretary mayorkas secretary mayorkas is
the first latino and immigrant confirmed
to serve as secretary of homeland
security
he has led a distinguished 30-year
career
as a law enforcement official and a
nationally recognized lawyer in the
private sector
he served as the deputy secretary of the
u.s department of homeland security from
2013-2016
and as a director of u.s citizenship and
immigration services
from 2009 to 2013 during his tenure at
dhs he led the development and
implementation of daca
negotiated cyber security and homeland
security agreements with foreign
governments
led the department's response to ebola
and zika helped build and administer the
blue campaign to combat human
trafficking
and developed an emergency relief
program for orphaned youth following the
tragic
2010 earthquake in haiti he's been kind
enough to offer to take some of your
questions as always i'll be the bad cop
cop with that i will turn it over to you
uh thank you very much jen and uh good
morning everyone
uh i'd like to spend a few minutes to
provide you with an overview
of what we have done and are continuing
to do and what we are dedicated
uh to achieving uh we are dedicated to
achieving
and quite frankly are working around the
clock to replace the cruelty of the past
administration with an orderly
humane and safe
immigration process it is hard
and it will take time but rest assured
we are going to get it done
let me explain to you why it is hard and
wide is going to
take time i think it is important to
understand what we have inherited
because it defines
the situation as it currently stands
entire systems are not rebuilt in a day
or in a few weeks to put it succinctly
the prior administration dismantled our
nation's
immigration system in its entirety
when i started 27 days ago i learned
that we did not have
the facilities available or equipped
to administer the humanitarian laws that
our congress passed
years ago we did not have the personnel
policies procedures or training to
administer
those laws quite frankly the entire
system
was gutted in addition
uh they tore down of the central
american miners program
that allowed children to access
laws of protection without having to
take the perilous journey
north they cut off funding to the
northern triangle countries of guatemala
el salvador and honduras no planning had
been done
to protect the frontline personnel of
the u.s customs and border protection
uh and other front line per se personnel
that address the needs of individuals
coming to our border
contracts had been entered that were
unlawful
or against the interests of the united
states department of
justice and that's just the tip of it
and i must tell you that it pains me
profoundly
to say this today on march 1st
the 18th anniversary of the us
department of homeland security
it takes time to rebuild an entire
system
and to process individuals at the border
in a safe and just way that is
especially true
when we're in the midst of the pandemic
and are obligated of course
to adhere to the restrictions and
procedures
that have been promulgated by the cdc to
ensure public safety
including the safety of the individuals
who arrive
at our border it takes time to build
out of the depths of cruelty that the
administration
before us established what we
are see seeing now at the border
is the immediate result of the
dismantlement
of the system and the time that it takes
to rebuild it virtually we
have though already begun
and to design and in fact have begun to
implement a new innovative way to
address the needs
of the population that was forced to
remain in mexico
during the prior administration that
rebuilding
that innovative solution is but one part
of a multi-part
strategy to execute on the president's
vision
for example we've also begun to rebuild
the process
for young people to be able to access
avenues of protection without having to
take
uh the perilous journey we have begun to
develop and rebuild
the program to reunify individuals with
their families here
in the united states as was once the
case
the president set forth his bold vision
in his executive orders at the outset of
his administration
and we are driven to implement them
successfully
let me if i can take a a couple minutes
to explain that innovative system to
which i referred with respect to
how we are addressing the individuals
who were forced into the remain
in mexico program under the prior
administration
working very closely with the mexican
government and international
organizations in mexico we have
developed a virtual platform that
enables
individuals with active cases in the
remaining
mexico program to actually register
for relief using their phones the
international organizations then work
with those
individuals to test them process their
cases
and transport them safely and according
to a
defined schedule to the port of entry
where we
are awaiting them and can process them
through the port of entry uh
successfully
we started with one port and 25
individuals
a day we are now at three ports and we
have
um enhanced our processes at one of
those three ports
to reach a hundred individuals a day in
processing
to address the acute need in the camper
at matamoros which we have all um heard
so much about this is all
by the way at a time when we are also
addressing the needs of our frontline
personnel uh
soon after i took office on february
2nd we launched operation vow vaccinate
our workforce
where we have really surged resources
and capabilities
according to the paradigm that has been
established by the covet 19
task force to address the needs of
frontline personnel throughout the
federal government
in february alone we have vaccine we
started at two percent of that frontline
personnel workforce
vaccinated at the end of february uh we
were um
we were able uh uh to reach 20 percent
of the front line personnel i have to
take this opportunity
at the same time to reiterate a message
that we have communicated uh repeatedly
throughout
which is a message to those individuals
who are thinking of coming
to our border they need they need to
wait
it takes time to rebuild
the system from scratch
if they come if families come if
single adults come to the border
we are obligated to uh in the service of
public health
including the health of the very people
who are thinking of coming
um to impose the travel restrictions
under the cdc's title 42
authorities and return them
to mexico and we have done that
we need individuals to wait and i will
say that they will wait
with a goal in mind and that is
our ability to rebuild as
quickly as possible a system so that
they don't have to take the
the dangerous journey and we can uh
enable them to access humanitarian
relief
from their countries of origin
the fact of the matter is that families
and single adults are indeed being
returned
under the covet 19 restrictions
um let me then turn to the issue and the
challenge of unaccompanied children
because i know that much has been
reported about the handling of
unaccompanied children
and let me just explain the process if i
may
when an unaccompanied child reaches the
border
and comes in between the ports of entry
u.s customs and border protection
personnel specifically the united states
border patrol
brings that child to a border patrol
station for
processing the border patrol
is only a pass-through we are obligated
to turn that child over uh to the
department of health and human services
within 72 hours we are a pass-through
and then health and human services or
hhs of course
that is commonly referred to
addresses the needs of that child as
hhs is identifying and vetting
sponsors in whose trust the child can be
placed
while the child is in immigration
proceedings
and so we um have the child
for a maximum of 72 hours and of course
given the pandemic in its restrictions
uh given
the extreme weather conditions in texas
a critical part
that 72-hour time frame was certainly uh
under stress as we all know
and as we can all understand and then
children
are in hhs custody for an average of
about 31 or 32
days finally let me turn
to um i think the most powerful
and heartbreaking example um of the
cruelty that preceded
this administration and that is uh the
intentional separation of children
uh from their parents uh i am
uh the chairman i have the privilege of
serving at the president's
designation as the chairman of the
family reunification
task force uh the first lady has driven
us
uh to action through her personal
commitment to this moral imperative
and that moral imperative is to reunite
the families and restore them to the
fullest capacity that we as a united
states government
can do and i should say that we are not
doing it alone
we are working closely with council
for the separated family members
we are doing it along with
the countries of el salvador guatemala
and honduras i spoke
with the foreign minister of each of
those countries this past
friday we are doing it with
non-governmental organizations
and we intend to and will shortly
harness
the capabilities resources uh and desire
of the private sector this is an um
not only in all of government but all of
society
effort to do what is right we are
uh hoping to reunite the families either
here
or or in the country of origin we hope
to be in a position
to give them the election and if
in fact they seek to reunite here in the
united states
we will explore lawful pathways for them
to remain in the united states and to
address the family needs
so we are acting as restoratively
as possible i am very proud
uh and excited to announce uh that we
have hired
michelle branet as the executive
director of the family reunification
task force
she began late last week most recently
she served as a senior director
of the migrant rights and justice
program of the
women's refugee commission she has
dedicated
uh her entire career to human rights
and she is a extraordinary uh
talent uh that will bring justice
uh and uh to this effort
along with the resources of the
department of homeland security
the department of justice the department
of health and human services
and every other member of the federal
government that has resources
to bring to bear uh it is because
of the men and women of the department
of homeland security
and across the federal enterprise that
we will dig out
of the cruelty of the past
administration and we will
rebuild our nation's asylum system
uh and all of our humanitarian programs
of which we have been historically so
proud as a leader uh in the world and
with that jen
um i'm pleased to take questions
thank you secretary you mentioned that
it will take some time to uh rebuild the
department how long i mean obviously
you're asking the american people to be
patient these vibrants to be patient
um how long will it take to uh to to
rebuild these systems and proceeds and
staffing that you say you inherited uh
that were not there when you were
inheriting the agency and then also
on the family unification task force how
big is this population
of separated families right now
separating children
and how many have you already been able
to reunify and what's the timeline for
getting them all
unified um so uh in in but a few weeks
uh we already uh have designed
uh an innovative program to bring people
in through the ports of entry
uh those uh that most acutely in need by
reason
of the fact that they have been
remaining in mexico uh uh for so long
uh and we have already begun to
implement it we
are progressing every single day i don't
have a particular timeline
but all i can do is communicate both to
the american public
and to the individuals seeking
protection that we are working around
the clock
seven days a week to make that time
frame as short as possible
but they need to wait but they need to
wait with a particular goal in mind
we are not saying don't come we are
saying don't come
now because we will be able to deliver
a safe and orderly process to them
as quickly as possible there have been
i understand approximately 105 families
reunited in in the recent past
that is through the extraordinary
efforts of council and others in the
community
uh we are joining uh with council
with members of the community uh to work
on this and michelle will be full-time
and we are dedicating resources
full-time across the
government uh and the department of
homeland security specifically
uh to this effort the urgency of it
cannot be overstated
a question about how unaccompanied
migrant children are handled the process
that you articulated is the same as it
was under former president trump it's
the same as it was under former
president biden
the difference as i understand it with
the trump administration was that they
held children
for a longer period of time how can that
process be sped up there are immigration
advocates who say most kids who come
here out of company
have the name or a phone number of a
relative here in the u.s and that they
should be matched with them promptly
so let me let me if i may uh correct um
uh
one of the premises of of your of your
question but you said
that we're handling them in the same way
that the trump administration did and
that is
that is absolutely um uh inaccurate
well actually the trump administration
expelled children
uh to mexico uh uh and we are not
expelling young children we are not
apprehending a nine-year-old child
who's come alone who's traversed mexico
uh whose parents whose loving parents
had sent that child
alone we're not expelling that
nine-year-old child
uh to mexico uh when that child's origin
country of origin was guatemala honduras
or el salvador
we are actually bringing that child into
a border patrol station
as a stepping point to get that child
in the hands of hhs that has the
capacity
and the and the unique talents to care
for the
child healthcare workers mental health
counseling and the like
and moving that child to a sponsor as
quickly as possible
so we have taken a look at the process
that is in place
and we are re-engineering it to see for
example whether we could have hhs
personnel
collate co-located in a border patrol
station
start to identify the needs of the child
to see if that child does indeed have
a relative in the united states identify
the sponsor more quickly
and unite that child with the sponsor
more quickly
more quickly so a re-engineering we are
taking a look at
where efficiencies uh can be achieved
in the best interest of the child it is
the best interest of the child that
really define our actions if i may
just quickly looking at the principles
that you laid out at the work of the
family reunification task force
i didn't see in their accountability
making sure that it never happens again
but also holding the trump
administration's responsible for that
policy
holding them accountable the justice
department inspector general put out
basically a roadmap
that says that jeff sessions and doj
leadership at the time was responsible
for that
enforcing that zero tolerance policy so
so um it's a
very important um first of all those
principles
are our guide uh we are going to be
discussing
what can we do under the law because
remember we must address the needs of
each
family member in an individualized way
each family unit
in an individualized way in accordance
with the law
so these are our goals our overarching
goal
is uh of course uh to be as humane
as the law provides to be as restorative
as the law enables us to be to bring
justice to these families
one of the tasks of the reunification
task force
will be of course in addition to
reuniting
those families which of course is the
most acute urgency
to also take a look at the system and
ensure to your uh very important
question
to ensure that it does not happen again
as the president has so powerfully said
this is not who we are
mr secretary in south texas uh
several city officials are requesting
coveted tests from the state of texas
for migrants what plan is dhs putting in
place
to do coveted testing for migrants so
if i can level set um on that
the the extraordinary weather that that
texas
uh suffered and to which the president
responded with such urgency
uh created a um an unexpected stress
uh on our system as a matter of process
uh individuals of family units are
brought into ice
custody they are tested ice has the
capability to test them uh
to isolate and quarantine them as the
results so dictate
and then to address their needs as the
immigration process
uh uh provides so
so is it happening right now yes it is
okay if i can also ask you said please
don't come you sent the message now is
not the time what specifically
and how is this administration conveying
that message to these desperate families
and you know people who respectfully
probably will not heed your warning to
please don't come now what are you doing
to convey the message
to them so um multi-part
answer if i may uh number one of course
with respect to our resources we are
flooding uh the space with that critical
message
uh i cannot overstate its criticality
for the well-being of those very
individuals who are thinking of coming
uh not to mention the well-being uh and
stability of the border as we seek to
rebuild it
uh from its dismantled state we are not
communicating alone we are communicating
in partnership
with non-governmental organizations
community-based organizations
that do have the ear of these very
communities
and we are doing it in tandem with the
governments of mexico el salvador
guatemala
and honduras it is
it's very difficult to know um those
whom we
have successfully deterred uh but our
understanding
uh is that it does work to a degree
certainly with certain aspects of the
population
uh and it is a message that we need to
continue to communicate
it is our obligation uh as a nation to
do so
mr secretary thank you mr secretary um
do you believe that right now there is a
crisis
at the border i think that the uh the
answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
and we have our resources dedicated to
to managing it
and so a lot of the things that you are
talking about you admit
take some time to implement but right
now you've got about
200 migrant children crossing the border
every single day
cbp projected a peak of 13 000
unaccompanied children
in the month of may according to a
report in axios
what is being done between now and then
when you're able
to implement all the things that you're
talking about that you say will take
time
let me let me answer that question with
tremendous pride
um the men and women of the department
of homeland security
are working around the clock seven days
a week
to ensure that we do not have a crisis
at the border that we manage
the challenge as acute as the challenge
is
and they are not doing it alone this is
a challenge that the border communities
the non-governmental organizations uh
the people who
care for individuals seeking
humanitarian relief
all understand it is an imperative
everyone understands
what occurred before us what we need to
do now
and we are getting it done respectfully
one of your predecessors
jay johnson he said that a thousand
illegal border crossings a day
constitutes a crisis that it overwhelms
the system we're at between
three and four thousand now according to
cbp officials so
how is this not a crisis um i have
explained that quite clearly i
um we are challenged at the border
the men and women of the department of
homeland security
are meeting that challenge it is a
stressful challenge
and we are that is why quite frankly we
are working
as hard as we are not only in addressing
the urgency of the challenge
uh but also in building the capacity to
manage it
and to meet our humanitarian aspirations
and execution of the president's vision
go ahead ashley uh thank you mr
secretary does the administration
support using budget reconciliation to
legalize
millions of undocumented immigrants this
year as senator warren and 100 other
democratic lawmakers have called for
um the president on day one sent a bill
to congress uh the president uh uh
recently uh spoke
uh of that bill uh that bill
uh addresses what uh there is
unanimity about which is we are
operating under a broken immigration
system
and we need to fix it specifically would
you consider using the budget
reconciliation
it is not for me to decide the
legislative strategy
that the administration employs the
administration is committed
to passing immigration legislation uh
and the administration um is pursuing a
path that everyone
understands is directly needed
you said that the previous
administration had entered into some
contracts that were unlawful
could you give some examples of that
what do you mean let me let me give you
an example that already has been uh in
the public domain quite frankly
um and that is uh the uh
agreement on january 19th one day before
the new administrative
uh agreement uh with
the union uh of immigration and customs
enforcement
that the union must approve any policy
changes
in the immigration arena i had no i've
been in government
uh for um almost 20 years
now i've never seen a contract like that
and i certainly haven't seen a contract
like that
on the last day of an administration
karen
uh thank you mr secretary i'm with abc
news and we've reached out to hhs and
border patrol after the suggestion from
jen last week to try and gain access to
the tent facilities in texas
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't quite hear
but let me if i can
say one thing um back to that question
if i may
because there can be um honest
disagreements about policy
but there has to be an overriding um
credo and that is loyalty to our
institutions
and what they stand for and the
fundamental rule of law
and i find an agreement like that um
in dereliction of that duty yes i'll
project this time sorry
sorry i apologize i'm with abc we
reached out to hhs and the border patrol
about gaining access to the tent
facilities in texas
we were told we can't because of covet
restrictions if there is a safe way to
do this to get reporters down there
to show the american people the
conditions there where these
unaccompanied children are being held
would you allow that
um i'm happy to take a look at that i
owe it to my people
to understand the situation and the
reasons
why access was denied i will share with
you
uh something um another um
principle to which i intend to hear
throughout my
uh tenure and that's openness and
transparency
and uh that includes the fourth estate i
actually uh grew up as a journalism
student but apparently i wasn't a good
enough writer to make it the whole way
um let me let me share with you um
uh what i what i communicate to the
workforce and we'll leave it uh
at that um because it's in the service
of openness and transparency
don't shrink from criticism just work
very hard not to deserve it
thank you very much all right oh i'm
happy to take my question
what is the status of the review of the
trump era visa bans for h1b visas and
has the white house decided to lift
those bans before they expire at the end
of the month
you know i don't really uh i hate to end
the questioning on an uh on a question
the
the answer to which i am not certain but
but look
uh this goes to what preceded us
we have so much work to do to repair
and to restore and to rebuild
that we have a prioritization matrix
and of course the acute needs of
individuals
fleeing persecution is a high priority
which brings me
uh to this uh meeting this morning thank
you everyone
secretary we'd love to have you back
again there's clearly lots of questions
thank you so much
thank you
okay just have a few more things there's
only one more thing at the top
um obviously the president's focus
this week in the coming weeks until it's
passed is on the american rescue plan
and i wanted to take the opportunity to
reiterate that in two weeks on march
14th
around 11 million americans will start
losing their unemployment benefits if
congress doesn't act on the president's
rescue plan there are 11 million
americans who are unemployed through no
fault of their own
but who will struggle to put food on the
table struggle to make ends meet and
struggle to live with the dignity they
deserve
i'd also note that nearly 1 million
households on an employment insurance
report that their children
aren't eating enough more than 1.5
million more are behind on their rent
or mortgage uh for almost a full year
now new
unemployment claims have exceeded the
pre-pandemic all-time high
and the economic data shows a k-shaped
recovery with millions of workers at
risk of being
left behind that's why it's absolutely
critical congress act and we certainly
hope they do that
as quickly as possible one last note
today as many of you know all of you
know
uh the president will meet with
president andres manuel lopez
obrador uh the president of mexico
building on their uh
their january 22nd conversation the
meeting will reaffirm the enduring
partnership between both countries
based on mutual respect and the
extraordinary bond of family and
friendship
the president will be joined for the
meeting by secretary of state tony
blinken
secretary of homeland security alejandro
mayorkas spending a lot of time here
today clearly
and other white house officials to
discuss a new phase of the u.s mexico
bilateral relationship
with their counterparts the discussion
we expect will focus on migration
recovery from kovid
19 climate change and security with that
zeke kick it off thank you again uh
what's the white house's response to
iran's uh
refusal to sit down from the uh for uh
negotiations on a two-year program and
is there a sense of urgency in the part
of white house to go on to the table
given
the development progression of this
program well
um first let me say we're disappointed
in iran's response we remain ready to
re-engage in meaningful diplomacy to
achieve a mutual return to compliance
with jcpoa commitments and we will be
consulting at every level with our p5
plus one partners
on the best way forward we do view this
though as a part of a diplomatic process
to determine the way forward and that's
what we'll be engaging through the prism
another foreign policy the president has
not taken any
direct action against the saudi crown
prince in response to his involvement
in the murder of journalists um
why not and what message is the
president saying to autocrats around the
world
that they could kill journalists or
their own citizens with impunity and
not suffer personal things well let me
first say that
um you know this was a horrific crime uh
the president has been consistent in
reiterating that and his belief
of that uh the report that was released
on friday
through odni uh did not contain new
information it was important to the
president that it was released
and it divided by our legal obligations
and it wasn't something
that was done by the prior
administration we also took a series of
strong steps to impose on individuals
directly involved in the operation
that led to the murder of jamal
khashoggi including adding
a senior saudi intelligence official
ahmed al-asiri to the list of those
facing
uh global magnitsky global magnitude
designation i don't know why that's a
mountful we also sanctioned
under the global magnitsky rule the
entire rapid intervention force
a unit of the saudi royal guard that has
engaged in counter-dissident operations
including the operation that resulted in
the killing of
jamal khashoggi this is a crucial step
because it structurally addresses an
unacceptable pattern of targeting
monitoring harassment and threats to
dissidents and journalists and we
believe
our team our national security team
believes that going after the network
responsible for these actions
is the best way to prevent a crime like
this from ever happening again
that is our objective going after the
network responsible but not the
man responsible for it why not uh
again you know i would say we took a
number of steps that our team determined
were the right steps to prevent this
from ever happening again
that is our objective we also from day
one even prior to the release of this
report
have recalibrated the relationship have
made clear that is going to be a shift
from how it was approached over the last
four years
that means counterpart to counterpart
conversations that means not holding
back and voicing concern
and pushing for action as it relates to
dissidents or journalists or others
being held
and it means making clear that we are
not going to support the ongoing
war in yemen we want to find a
conclusion of that war
so our objective is to recalibrate the
relationship
prevent this from ever happening again
and find ways as there are still
to work together with saudi leadership
while still making clear where we feel
action is unacceptable
he spoke yesterday about the sexual
harassment allegations against governor
former
new york has anyone from the white house
reached out directly to anyone to him or
anyone on his staff
and then is the president concerned that
this could serve as a distraction
from governor cuomo's handling of the
pandemic and should be
potentially step aside while this
investigation is underway
so that there are no distractions
handling
well as i stated yesterday
um the president's view has been uh
consistent and clear that every woman
coming forward should be treated treated
with dignity and respect
that applies to charlotte that applies
to lindsay and any woman
coming forward and since yesterday of
course overnight
the attorney general has been made clear
that the attorney general
the new york attorney general will
oversee an independent investigation
with subpoena power
and the governor's office said he will
fully cooperate
we certainly support that process and
we'll we'll wait to see that through
go ahead just to follow up you reserve
the right to sanction the crown prince
in the future if deemed necessary right
of course we reserve the right to take
any action at a time and manner of our
choosing i will note
steve that uh historically uh the united
states through democratic and republican
presidents has not typically
sanctioned government leaders of
countries where we have
diplomatic relations and a separate
question we saw the statement last night
about
alabama and amazon is the president
endorsing
amazon workers forming a union there
well the president uh broadly i think it
was a video
that uh just so people know the context
of what you're referring to
uh the president believes that workers
should have the right to organize
uh that is a fundamental um uh value he
has and one that he has
been consistent on for decades we don't
comment on specific cases where it is
before the nlrb or could be before the
nlrb so we aren't going to weigh in
specifically
on amazon but we uh broadly he believes
that
workers should have the right to
organize and hence he conveyed that in
the video
on burma myanmar have you been forceful
enough in your sanctions on myanmar
because
we keep seeing these bloody crackdowns
and are you coordinating with allies
to look at more actions uh we are
absolutely we put out a statement
uh yesterday from national security
adviser jake sullivan let me just
reiterate a couple of the pieces from
that
uh that we remain alarmed by the burmese
security forces violent
uh violence against peaceful protesters
the killings represent an escalation of
the ongoing crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters since the february first
coup uh we are preparing the additional
actions to impose further costs on those
responsible for this latest outbreak of
violence
and the recent coup and we expect to
have more to share in that in the coming
days
uh go ahead and on back on saudi arabia
during the campaign obviously
former vice president turbine was very
well aware of the history
of the us government in terms of who
they sanction and who they haven't but
yet he said
we're going to make them pay the price
and make them the pariah that they are
how does this come anywhere close to his
pledge
to americans in november of 2018 at that
debate
well first the president has been clear
to his team and he's been clear publicly
that the relationship is not going to
look like what it's looked like in the
past
and even before the release of the port
report on friday
we had taken actions as an
administration to make that clear
through diplomatic conversations to our
partners and allies in the region
and through our actions and that
includes uh
a change in how we are communicating
with the saudis counterpart to
counterpart going back to
that appropriate line of communication
it includes not holding back and raising
concerns about human rights abuses
we did see last month that saudi arabia
did release
two dual national prisoners and women's
rights activists
it includes uh pulling back from our
support from the war in yemen
but it's important to also note that
there are areas where
we have a important relationship with
saudi arabia intelligence sharing
also helping defend against the threats
and the rocket attacks that they are
getting
um you know getting from bad actors
right at their doorstep and you know
global diplomacy requires
holding countries accountable when
needed
but also acting in the national interest
of the united states and that's exactly
what the president's trying to do
does he feel he's done a good enough job
explaining his position
his new position now as president of the
american people and how is he reacting
to the criticism he's received over the
weekend
and nick kristof the new york times uh
accused him of choking
i know there were a variety of pretty
tough uh words against him how does he
respond to that and does he need to
address it more
well i i don't think anyone runs for
president or is elected if they have a
thin skin
and certainly any action you take on
an issue like like global diplomacy or
an issue where there's a complicated
relationship
i think he fully expected there might be
some criticism but his
objective his role as president of the
united states and as commander of
chief of the country is to act in the
national interests of
the united states and that's exactly
what he's doing in this relation in this
uh in this case uh that he's acting on
the advice of his national security team
and he believes this is the right
approach for our long-term interest
really quickly you said there are 14
days obviously a very critical 14 days
to getting
really passed what specifically will he
be doing
directly with democratic senators and
republican senators perhaps will he
reach out to
susan collins for example or other
republicans to try and get them on board
obviously the republicans were not on
board in the house
absolutely i think we're going to be
evaluating day by day what the needs are
so as you know he'll be meeting with our
via zoom a number of uh democrats
democratic senators this afternoon
uh we reserve time in his schedule to
ensure that he can be engaged roll up
his sleeves and be personally involved
in
making phone calls having more zoom
meetings
potentially having people here to the
oval office to get this across the
finish line and i expect him to be
very involved personally on the
parliamentarian decision you said that
he respects
that decision but progressives don't
understand this in some respects they're
like why not
fight for this so why is the white house
not
more aggressively challenging that and
sending the vice president to try
and potentially overrule that with the
vote well uh the
the decision for a vice the vice
president to uh
vote to overrule or to take a step to
overrule is not a simple decision uh it
would also require 50 votes
as you know it's not a one-step decision
and the president and the vice president
both respect uh the history of the
senate and they are both
formally served in the senate and that's
not an action we intend to take
but i the president is committed to
raising the minimum wage
to working to determine the best vehicle
forward to doing that
that's why he put it in the package he
wants it to be raised to 15
an hour and he will be in touch with uh
leaders
from all wings of the party and
determining the best path forward for
that
go ahead jeff follow up to jeff's
question which strikes me the
the white house doesn't have 50 votes to
confirm near a tandem as omb
director and yet we've heard from the
white house chief of staff say that the
white house is they're going to fight
their guts out find our guts off with
the praise he used
to get her confirmed so why push for
that
and not push as hard one could say for
raising the minimum wage you could
make the argument that the american
people stand to benefit more from a
higher wage than they would from a
chosen omb director
well i think that's mixing a few things
kind of irresponsibly if i'm just being
totally honest
i would say on the minimum wage the
president included a raise of the
minimum wage in his package
because he felt strongly that it's long
overdue that men and women working hard
trying to make ends meet shouldn't be
living at the poverty level that's why
he put it in his package
there is a process that it goes through
a parliamentary process
when it's a reconciliation bill as you
know but for people who haven't been
following all the nitty gritty of this
because it's a budgetary bill that's why
it went through the process
and you know again i would i would send
you to talk to leaders in congress to
see if they have the 50 votes necessary
but regardless
the president the vice president have
made the decision they're not going to
move forward
with that step but also it's not a
simple process it requires two steps
as it relates to nira tandon she is
somebody who has decades of experience
uh she is qualified she is prepared to
lead the budget
team and uh we'll continue of course to
fight for the confirmation of
uh of every nominee that the president
puts forward
we'll see if we have 50 votes that's
part of the journey that's part of
democracy in action
oh good uh on voting rights the supreme
court is set to hear a major voting
rights case this week
you have by some estimates from 43
states republican-led states that are
set to at least envision a change to
election laws and want to make it harder
but it put in place more restrictions on
voting the house is set to vote on the
john lewis voting rights act that is
running headlong into a senate
filibuster
does the president support nixing the
filibuster
as a means of passing voting rights and
if not how is he going to leverage his
political capital
to make sure this democratic priority
becomes law
well first the president is committed to
protecting the fundamental right to vote
and making it easier for all
eligible americans to vote his campaign
was about fighting
for democracy and we're going to
continue to fight for democracy in the
white house
and that's why we need to pass reforms
like hr1
the for the people act and restore the
voting rights act and he's happy to see
the house take up h.r 1
this week we're not going to get ahead
of the process the president's view on
the filibuster is well known
uh he has not changed that point of view
but certainly
any step to protect voting rights to
ensure that it's easier and not harder
for people to vote in the country we
feel is a positive step
okay ashley go ahead uh thank you i want
to follow up on governor cuomo and then
i have a question about sure
um you said uh president biden supports
an independent review of the sexual
harassment allegations against him um
but one of those aides 25 year old
charlotte benefit
bennett rather detailed specific
language and questions that she said the
governor asked her about her personal
life that made her feel
uncomfortable and the governor himself
has not denied
asking these personal questions so my
question for you is in general when it
comes to sexual misconduct
where is the red line for this president
and the administration is it only
unwanted physical overtures or is it
unwelcome language between a boss and a
subordinate with a power differential
well ashley as i
as i said yesterday that story was
incredibly uncomfortable to read
as a woman um and we certainly believe
that every woman coming forward
charlotte
lindsay have should be treated with
respect and dignity and
be able to tell their story uh and
treated with respect
uh there is a process of reviewing as
you noted
um an independent investigation we will
leave it to that process through the
attorney general
to make a determination on the path
forward in general that not about this
specific case but can you just explain i
mean your white house accepted the
resignation of someone who
used simply language that was
inappropriate and abusive
is there a red line when it comes just
to language
or is uh president biden's red line does
it have to be something i'm not sure a
red line for whom i'm not sure what you
mean
and what could it like with what outcome
for if
the review shows that governor cuomo
asked her
questions um it's not you know as has
also been alleged in other instances
of forcible kiss or an unwelcome
physical overture but just mere
questions about someone's personal life
or sex life or romantic life or anything
that makes someone
feel uncomfortable especially in a
subordinate um
a relationship with someone in power is
that something where someone should
have to resign or should there be other
consequences that's what i mean by it
look the the language the
um you know the president has a bar for
what is expected in his administration
which you referenced uh treating people
with civility
uh treating people with respect and
that's what bar he holds in his
administration in terms of the path
forward
and the outcome of the investigation we
will leave it to the attorney general
and others to conclude that
and then on schools first i want to make
sure i understand president biden's 100
day pledge to reopen schools
is that getting 51 of k-8 schools open
five days a week am i correct on that uh
the majority of schools open five days a
week that is certainly our objective and
we'd like to meet that within 100 days
and we hope our secretary of education
is confirmed soon we'll be
overseeing that process moving forward
five days a week
is that every single kid who wants to be
in school that individual kid
is going five days a week or is that the
building open five days a week
but kids perhaps doing a hybrid model
half the class on mondays and wednesdays
the other half on
we'd like kids to be able to be in
school five days a week thank you
go ahead kristen thank you jen um so
when the president of mexico meets with
president
later today he's expected to ask if
president biden would consider
sharing part of the us chronovirus
vaccine supply
with his country is this something that
president biden is considering
no the president has made clear that he
is focused on ensuring that vaccines are
accessible to every american
that is our focus the next step is
economic recovery
and that is ensuring that our neighbors
mexico and canada have similarly managed
the pandemics that we can
open borders open our borders and build
back better but our focus is
on his focus the administration's focus
is on ensuring that every
american is vaccinated and once we
accomplish that objective we're happy to
discuss
uh further steps beyond that one other
thing that the president of mexico is
expected to propose
is an idea to bring an immigrant labor
program to the u.s that could bring
600 to 800 000 immigrants a year to work
legally in the united states is that
something president biden would consider
i
i've seen reports of that i believe
that's a step that would require
congress i'm sure we'll have a readout
after uh the
bilateral meeting this afternoon and
they both will be speaking after it as
well
okay one more question about the strike
in syria
uh the democratic senator mark warner he
said over the weekend that he really
wished that the biden administration had
given congress
more of a heads up he said i wish the
biden team would have given congress
greater knowledge
and greater warning so given the
criticism that you and
other administration officials had
leveled at the trump administration
uh when they strike syria back in 2017
why not go more out of the way to loop
in congress
well there were notifications made um to
the appropriate um
committee chairs and uh there but there
has also been an offer of classified
briefings to anyone who would like a
classified briefing
and we concluded a range of
notifications on friday
uh in terms of uh the strike in 2017
uh that was a strike of uh that would
excuse me that was a
that was a an attack on uh on syrian
militant
military installations in response to a
chemical weapons attack
this was in response to a threat and
attacks that threatened the lives of
american men and women serving overseas
they're both different in policy
and legal justification one more
question
from former president trump over the
weekend speaking at cpac
i heard that he said
president joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers union how does the white
house respond to that
uh i think we're going to uh uh spend
more of our time focused on
communicating about our agenda for the
american people
than responding to uh criticism from
uh the former president uh go ahead
thanks jen um to go back to uh saudi and
the crown prince and the quote that jeff
brought up from then
candidate joe biden in 2019 you
mentioned uh
holding countries accountable you
mentioned today acting in the national
interest he said in 2019
we're going to make them pay the price
saudi leaders how is the administration
making the crown prince pay a price and
are you saying that
the national interest and holding them
accountable can't square with
paying a price no i'm certainly not
saying that i was outlining a number of
the steps that were announced on friday
that were taken that specifically
addressed
uh sanctioned the deputy head of
intelligence that
specifically uh sanctioned under the
magnitsky act the entire rapid
intervention force which is a force that
is close to
um the uh the crown prince um and i was
referring to specifically
our uh goal of recalibrating the entire
relationship which is something that we
started to do from day one of the
administration we did not
wait for the release of the report but i
was also noting that
this is a country where we have
diplomatic relations we are going to
hold them accountable we are going to
take steps we are not going to hold back
on making clear where actions are
unacceptable where there needs to be a
change and reforms put in place
while also recognizing that there are
areas we need to continue to work
together on because they're in the
interests of the united states and our
own security you mentioned the
historically not sanctioning leaders of
foreign governments that we have
diplomatic relations with you
then you said it yesterday is it the
policy though of the biden
administration
to not sanction a foreign leader if
there are diplomatic relations more than
just precedent but actual policy
it's considerations considerations are
done on a case-by-case basis but i think
that's an important
uh precedent because obviously taking
that step
is something that there is not a great
deal of historic precedent for and that
was why i noted it
the intelligence community's conclusion
that the crown prince approved the
murder operation the murder of jamal
khashoggi
if that's not something that would
change the precedent what would
again we took a number of steps that
were
uh considered and determined by our
national security team
to have the intended impact of
preventing this from ever happening
again
and not just in saudi arabia but around
the world including the implementation
of the khashoggi rule
allowing the state department to
restrict or evoke visas to any
individual believed to be
targeting perceived dissidents or
journalists including the sanctions that
i've just outlined against the saudi
rapid intervention force against the
deputy head of
general intelligence for his role in the
operation
we have also conveyed uh very clearly
uh and candidly uh through diplomatic
channels
that this absolutely can never happen
again that our relationship will be
different
from what it has been in the past and
that we are going to be
uh of course hold the option of holding
uh
of holding um uh uh you know
saudi arabia to to their commitment uh
to uh
to to take uh put reforms in place uh
and and make progress moving forward
go in the back thank you i've got a
couple questions just like my front row
colleagues
sure um given that the white house
promised to release
visitor logs why hasn't the
administration divulged to the president
is meeting with virtually i mean we're
in the middle of a pandemic isn't that
kind of transparency
really important and also wouldn't be
really easy to do he's
meeting with members of the senate
virtually today there i've released it
for you what else would you like to know
oh i think we did release the names if
we haven't we certainly have every
intention of doing that this afternoon
very good um we've been talking a lot
about congress and sort of the log jam
that has been i'm wondering is the
president
looking at uh the proposal that was
released by house appropriations chair
rosa delora when it comes to bringing
earmarks back is that something that
i know that he's a legislator himself
but is that something that
he's interested in maybe that could
hurry along some of the agenda or
does he not have an opinion on your
marks i i have not discussed that with
our legislative team obviously as you
noted he was in the senate for 36 years
we are our focus right now is on the
american rescue plan uh you're familiar
with all the components of that bill
because we talk about it
constantly from here uh but i don't have
any
new position or a position on that
particular piece of legislation i will
check and see if there's anything more
we would like to convey
go ahead oh sorry go ahead go ahead
thank you
senator warren proposed a wealth tax on
households that are worth at least 50
million
saying quote this is money that should
be invested in child
care and early education infrastructure
all of which are priorities of president
biden and democrats in congress
does this president have any appetite
for wealth tax
well the president strongly believes
that the ultra wealthy and corporations
need to finally start paying
their fair share and that our economy
and tax system need to reward work
not wealth that's why he proposed making
sure the very
uh richest americans pay the same rate
on the income from their wealth
that a worker pays as well as closing
loopholes that allow them to entirely
escape
tax obviously our focus is on the
american rescue plan
addressing uh the inequities in the tax
code is something he talked about as
part of his buildback better agenda
and is something he remains committed to
he's a lot of respect for senator warren
and is aligned on the goal of ensuring
the ultra wealthy and big corporations
finally pay their fair share he's laid
out a lot of ideas and when we get to
that point in our agenda he'll look
forward to working with her and others
in congress
go ahead thank you jen very much so
yesterday former president trump
suggested he might run again in um
he'll be back in 2024. you said like how
does not pay attention to
to president trump from president trump
but how do you think foreign leaders are
looking
at this because this is one of the
reasons foreign allies are still
still have doubts and many um
if they can trust anyone again so how do
you also
think president biden can convince
global
allies that they can trust the united
states and reclaim
u.s leadership well the president
president biden
uh just decisively beat uh donald trump
a few months ago that's why we're all
here
having so much fun together in here uh
and uh but his focus and i think one of
the ways that he convinces
foreign allies and partners that america
is back and we we want to seat at the
table
is by keeping his focus on his
commitments he made
on the campaign trail which is building
the economy back better
bringing it into the pandemic rebuilding
our relationships around the world
and not focusing time and energy and
effort on a political campaign
there's plenty of time for that but his
focus is on uh
his objectives of uh getting the
pandemic under control working with our
partners around the world to do that as
well
take into consideration that foreign
allies are worried about
the return of donald trump i i am not a
spokesperson for our foreign partners so
you'd have to ask them and see what they
have to say
i have one more question about sure so
sure the who
said that it is a tragedy happening in
brazil right now
because of the pandemic uh what is the
white house evaluation of
the situation in brazil and how brazil
is responding to this crisis
well first let me note that on just
about a month ago
the united states through the u.s
through usaid announced it has delivered
an addition of 1.5 million dollars for
emergency covid19 response
in brazil we did that of course because
we want to be a collaborative and
cooperative partner in addressing the
pandemic
our focus is on uh here
is on getting uh the american people
vaccinated that needs to be our focus
now
but of course we believe that uh the
more people in our global community who
are vaccinated the safer we all are it's
just what our current focus is
uh at this point in time it's in
conversation with the brazilian
government
about the situation there do you think
also there is a tragedy going on in
brazil right now happening in brazil
certainly the loss of life the number of
people have been
impacted in brazil and many places in
the world including the united states is
an incredible tragedy
uh but in terms of specific
conversations i'd refer you to the state
department they would have more
specifics
and more updated conversations to read
out for you go ahead just one more
question about
uh south america there was uh some hope
in south america the president baid
badin would be an ally because he was
he has experienced leading issues in the
region during the obama administration
but so far in more than a month
president biden has not spoken with any
leader
in south america so i wonder what would
be his uh
priority in the region and also who
might be
his best partner in the region who would
be the first one he would call
we'll see i i promise you that the
president would love to spend even more
time calling
foreign leaders and there's just a lot
of course on his schedule i expect he
will do many more
foreign leader calls in the coming weeks
and certainly would
have discussions with many leaders in
south america but i don't have any
prediction for you about who or when
go ahead during the code briefing
earlier today jeff science
acknowledged that you know people were
having a lot of frustration getting
vaccine appointments
a lot of problems with the state portals
is there any discussion at this point
given those problems
with setting up some sort of nationwide
portal for people to access those
vaccine appointments
well there was an announcement we made
last week about
uh vaccine finder and it's just
available of course in about a half a
dozen states at this point in time
but what we're working to do is take a
number of steps to ensure people have
access to
more easily figure out when they can get
a vaccine when they're eligible in part
because as you know
everybody doesn't have access to the
internet everybody doesn't know how to
figure that out online
so certainly that's one tool it's in a
pilot stage at this point in time
certainly could be expanded but we're
also looking for
to add additional steps call centers uh
you know proactive outreach other ways
to reach people who are having trouble
figuring out
how to gain access to a vaccine and when
they'll be eligible
okay one more question if you don't mind
um senators widen and sanders dropped
their plan today
for taxing companies that did not uh pay
a higher minimum wage
i'm wondering what is the plan c at this
point for getting some sort of minimum
wage increase through
congress over the next several months
well it is
an issue that the president remains
committed to he wants the minimum wage
to be raised
um that's why he put it in his package
and he uh
is going to be in conversations and we
will be at a number of levels
uh with members of congress with their
staffs about the best vehicle moving
forward uh but we don't have
a clear answer on what that looks like
at this point it just remains a
commitment and something he will
use his um political capital to get done
good job and the white house has
anything has even standing up here
um the office has released the senators
who will be
meeting virtually with this afternoon
there are nine senators okay
um would you consider opening the top of
that up so we can hear from the
president directly
on this 14-day critical uh push
and if not why is that meeting not open
well it's a it's a video call
i'm happy to check with our team and see
um he does
he has spoken about his commitment to
getting the american rescue plan passed
and the reasons why
uh nearly on a daily basis so i don't
think you've had a shortage of that
he'll also be speaking
after the bilateral meeting with mexico
but i'll check and see if there's more
that can be done
uh go ahead um donald trump last night
said everybody should get their kobe 19
shot
is that something you would welcome his
intervention and given that republicans
as a group seem rather more reluctant to
get the
coronavirus vaccination is there more
you could be doing with republican
leaders to bring on that group
well that's a good question i mean our
objective of course is to ensure
um as many americans as possible uh are
vaccinated
as quickly as possible and we will have
enough vaccines to
vaccinate uh ensure every american has a
vaccine by the end of july if not sooner
likely sooner uh so our at a certain
point we're going to reach
uh we will have more vaccines than there
are people who want to take them that
doesn't seem like
where we're going to be at this point
but we will reach that point in time
and we certainly welcome the
encouragement from anyone to take a
vaccine
and if i could um ann sacalis is still
wanted in the uk on charges of causing
death by dangerous driving
now the original rationale for her
leaving the country with diplomatic
immunity was that she was the spouse
of somebody who was working at raf
crowton which under the terms of the
agreement there
meant she would have diplomatic
community it seems to have merged from
her lawyer in court here that she was
actually employed
by the state department or the u.s
intelligence services
i wonder if you can clarify whether she
was working in the uk
um for the united states government and
whether she does actually as far as
you're concerned have diplomatic
community
i would point to the state department
they of course engage in any questions
about
uh diplomacy diplomatic immunity um
of course the status of somebody who
served during the prior administration i
don't have anything more for you
from it on it from here go ahead in the
back uh hi thanks um can i ask about the
g7
uh in june sure can you lay out some of
what the president
wants to focus on there and um also is
it expected to be
his first overseas trip we're not quite
there yet
uh in terms of laying out his exact
agenda obviously there are
uh global objectives getting the
pandemic under control
working together to get our economy up
and going again which is something that
the united states is obviously grappling
with but many countries around the world
are grappling with
i'm certain those will be part of the
agenda but we're not quite at the point
of previewing a
uh summit that's happening in a few
months a lot can happen in the world
between now and then
uh in terms of whether or not uh he will
travel we haven't made a determination
on that
at this point either uh it it will be uh
related to
uh covid restrictions and um the advice
of our health and medical team and
expect as we get closer we'll have more
of an update that he won't pretend in
person
again we'll we'll evaluate as we get
closer there's certainly a possibility
um but
uh we're we are several months away go
ahead
um i have a couple questions about
strong myself and then something
sure go ahead um with three vaccines
available the administration has said it
will distribute
authority proportionally and then tell
states to distribute the technically
the question is that the johnson johnson
vaccine is just the one dose why not
prioritize prioritize that for
communities that are harder to reach
and maybe harder to convince to come
back and get that second dose
well the determination is made by the
fda
on kind of how these vaccines should be
distributed and where
i will say that the advice and guidance
we've been uh
we've we've received from our health and
medical team is that
uh every american should take whatever
vaccine is available
when it's their turn and in terms of
distribution of those vaccines generally
speaking
if we're distributing the johnson
johnson vaccine or we will distribute i
should say
just like we distribute pfizer and
modernise vaccine proportional to a
state's population and through
our federal channels so if a state makes
up five percent of the population it
will get five percent of the
pfizer allocation five percent of the
modern allocation
and five percent of the johnson and
johnson allocation
all three vaccines are highly effective
uh all three and this is certainly a
an incredible uh a step forward and a
new tool that we
have now in our uh in our um
quiver to address the crisis uh but uh
the guidance we are providing based on
the advice from our health and medical
team
is that any american should take uh
whatever vaccine
that is available to them can help the
administration
counteract any messaging that the
johnson johnson vaccine is
inferior to the other two that have
greater efficacy
well uh i think the clear uh message
we're sending is that
all of these vaccines are safe they are
effective
they've been approved by the fda they
will be distributed all of them will be
around the country
through governors and then also directly
to pharmacies and other mass vaccination
sites
and we will be continuing to convey that
um you know any vaccine you have access
to you should take that vaccine
and we are not uh there's no we will be
certainly also tracking
if vaccines are only going to certain
communities and we'll be addressing
those
issues as they come up a couple of
further colleagues on here
now that the coveted bill has passed the
house has the president had any more
contact with speaker pelosi
about scheduling his joint address to
congress that's such a popular question
uh i don't expect that we don't have any
update on it
i don't expect that uh the president
will uh
be laying out the next stage of his
agenda until after we get the american
rescue plan passed and we're certainly
hopeful that
we do that in the coming weeks his um
first press conference not yet but we
will definitely have one we will
schedule it and you will be the first to
know because you're pivotal participants
in that
last question here um when does
president biden plan to begin submitting
nominations for judicial vacancies
it's a great question it certainly is
something on his mind and a priority for
him uh given his long history
obviously as former chairman of the
judiciary committee i don't have an
update for you on the timing but uh it's
it's something that he has focused on
personally
in these conversations with foreign
leaders um phone calls and our meetings
uh is president discussing at all the
track of the white
white supremacy uh domestic violent
extremism
uh certainly it's uh it's a anyways but
you know
around the world that you're discussing
here in the u.s and around the world
well there's an ongoing review as you
know and we're allowing that policy
process to see itself through he does
receive regular updates from
his homeland security team and others on
incidents happening around the world
uh whether it comes up in meetings uh i
don't think i have anything more
specifically to
read out for you other than to convey
that it is a priority for him on the
national security
uh front in addressing that that's why
he asked his team to
uh conduct a full review and why we'll
look at that before we put new policies
in place
well white supremacy is a threat to the
national security and maybe further
transmit a transnational threat
he certainly wouldn't have asked the
national security team to conduct a full
review
of domestic violent extremism including
of course
activities of white supremacists if he
did not think it was a threat
thank you everyone
thank you